new video offers scientists encouraging
evidence for the survival of critically
endangered and rarely seen rhinoceroses
in Indonesia WWF recently released
motion-activated camera video captured
in the edge on coolin national park on
the island of java the first video shows
a female job in rhino with her male calf
walking through the rain forest and
munching on leaves at one point the calf
turns away and wags its tail possibly to
swat a fly WWF points out that the job
in rhino is one of the world's rarest
mammals with this view as 40 left in the
wild none are in captivity the confirmed
population exists on the western tip of
Java in the National Park it's small
concentrated population size contributes
to its vulnerability any natural
disaster could wipe out the remaining
animals in addition because of its
perceived medicinal qualities the Rhino
remains a target of poachers a job in
rhino was killed for its horn in 2010 in
Vietnam the second video shows a
different female and her female calf of
about one year of age a WWF scientist
says the videos are great news and prove
the rhinos are breeding in the park
conservationists hope to protect the
existing animals and establish a new
population through relocation
you